bon alors il va être quels sont tes
projets pour 88 alors là j'ai des
projets un très beau projet mais qui me
permettra de garder le secret parole du
candidat les noms dire à personne
on écoule annoncé ses taux non je ne
peux pas le dire je ne peux pas le dire
c'est quoi ça va venir je vais me
déguiser un charlot ah bon c'est bien
fait ça j'ai fait un numéro de music
hall je vais encore une fois cela allait
charlot qui sera de l'accordéon tu vois
c'est bien alors ça se prépare ça en
train de séparer spataro et qu'est ce
que tu souhaites au jour pour l'année 80
alors moi ce que je souhaite vraiment
une chose très sincèrement je dirais
beaucoup d'amour
c'est tendre la main tous les enfants du
monde soit heureux et ce sourire que
l'on s'amuse énormément avec l'accordéon
les autres
si voilà beaucoup de questions merci
bravo